مثل الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
امام قاضي في محكمه منهاتم بولايه نيويورك
الذي يواجه اكثر من ثلاثين تهمه تتعلق
بتزوير سجلات تجاريه بينها تهمه واحده على
الاقل ترقى الى مستوى الجنايه اتهم المدعي
العام في منعاه بتسريب معلومات على رائحه
الاتهام بطريقه وصفها بغير القانونيه سجل
بشان ابعاد المحاكمه
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي ظروف والاجواء
السياسيه والامنيه التي تجري فيها محاكمه
ترامب على ضوء استجار القانوني والسياسي
بشانها وما هي المسارات المحتمله لمحاكمه
اول رئيس امريكي بتهم جنائيه وكيف ستلقي
بظلالها على الامريكيين وكيف ستنعكس
محاكمه ترامب على المشهد في الولايات
المتحده سواء داخل الجمهوريين او على
الصعيد صراعهم السياسي مع الديمقراطيين
وسباق الرئاسه في 2024
[موسيقى]
بعد اخذ ورد لم يجد الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالدو بدا من الوثول امام القضاء
الامريكي لواجهه عشرات التهم التي تتعلق
بذمته الماليه واحده منها ترقى الى
المستوى الجنائي نشهد يختلط فيه القانوني
بالسياسي في سابقه من نوعها في التاريخ
السياسي للولايات المتحده الامريكيه ليس
فقط لان المعني هو رئيس امريكي سابق وانما
كذلك لكونه يخوض غماره حمله انتخابيه لنيل
ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري للانتخابات
2024 الرئاسيه
ويمر مسار محاكمه ترامب بمحطات اهمها مثول
الرئيس الامريكي السابق امام القاضي في
محكمه منهات كي يوجه له لائحه الاتهامات
التي بلغ عددها 30 وفي ختام سلسله من
الاجراءات الفنيه والقانونيه يقرر القاضي
والمارشان اذا كان سيمضي في المحاكمه
الجنائيه ام يوقفها جدير بذكر انه حتى في
حال ادانه ترامب بتهم جنائيه فلن يمنعه
ذلك من الترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه عامه
[موسيقى]
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
واشنطن ادولفو فرانكو المحلله الاستراتيجي
في الحزب الجمهوري ومن فيرجينيا نكرهها
عضو الكونغرس السابق عن الحزب الديمقراطي
ومن واشنطن خليل العناني السياسيه
والعلاقات الدوليه والباحث بالمركز العربي
في واشنطن ارحب بضيوفي جميعا وابدا
بادولفو فرانكو اذا كان معنا كيف يتابع
الجمهوريون هذه القضيه
سيد
الى ان ينضم الينا فرانكو ينضم الينال
بالنسبه
للديمقراطيين كيف تتابعون هذه القضيه
الديمقراطيون لا يشعرون بالبهجه في هذا
اليوم بالتاكيد لا ينبغي لهم ان يكونوا
كذلك لان هذا حدث تاريخي في تاريخ رواتب
المتحده وليست لحظه سعيده على الاطلاق
وعلينا ان ننتظر لنرى كيف تتكشف فصول هذه
الاحداث حسب علمي لا احد يعرف ماهيه التهم
والتوقع ان ذلك سنعرفه في ايه لحظه وبناء
على ذلك لا يمكن نتوقع ما هي الخطوات
التاليه
هناك اتهامات بتسييس هذه القضيه من اجل
التشويش على ترشيح او ترشح ترامب
للانتخابات الرئاسيه كيف ترد
هذا لا اعتقد ان التهم هي عباره عن تسييس
من جانب مدعي عامه مقاطعه منهات ولا اعتقد
ان هناك ما يكفي من القول للدعاء ذلك فهذا
الرجل له سمعه عاليه محترمه جدا كرجل
دائما يرتب اموره
ولديه قضايا محكمه من حيث
تهيئتها ومحاجزتها والقضيه ان مدعي عام
اخر لم يتخذ قرارا بالمضي قدما بهذه
القضيه هذا المدحي مدعي العام وجد نفسه
امام واجب قانوني ان يمضي قدما قبل ان
نفاذ الوقت القانوني للقضيه نعم دكتور
خليل عناني في اي سياق يمكن ان نفهم سير
هذه المحاكمه
سياسيا هناك سياق استقطاب حذف امريكا
نتحدث عن محاكمه تاريخيه لاول الرئيس سابق
او حالي في السلطه فيما يتعلق بمحاكمه
الجنائيه تهم جنائيه واضحه جدا والامر
متعلق بشخصيه هذا الشخص بالبروفايل بتاعه
بسلوك
بتعليقاته مستمره نتحدث عن شخص بحجم ترامب
وتاثيره ليس فقط في الجمهوريه بياض
الديمقراطيين نتكلم على الرئيس يتم محاوله
مرتين قبل ذلك ولم طبعا لم لم تنجح
المحاولتين نتكلم عن اول رئيس لم يعترف
بفشل وخطط الانتخابات الرئاسيه في 2020 او
الرئيس ايضا الان يتم التحكم الجنائيه او
عفوا تهم فيدراليه متعلقه بمحاوله نزول
الانتخابات في جورجيا بالاحتفاظ بوثائق
سريه عكس القانون كذلك بالتحريض على
اقتحام الكونجرس او الرئيس دحوم حوله
شبهات الى حد بعيد اخلاقيه ورغم ذلك ورغم
ذلك
يتصدر السباق الجمهوري على الاقل حتى هذه
اللحظه وبالتالي اتكلم عن سياق سياسي
يتميز بالاستقطاب الحاد ليس فقط
نعم الموضوع جنائي ام سياسي
يعني الموضوع بالاساس جنائي ومتعلق بالبعد
القضايا كان ايضا من الصعب استبعاد البعد
السياسي بنتكلم كما قلت قبل قليل الشخصيه
وزنها ثقيل جدا سياسيا ليس فقط داخل حزب
الجمهوري بل ايضا في الساحه الامريكيه
بشكل عام ترامب لمده ظهوره قبل سته اعوام
في الساحه السياسيه الكثير من الجدل نتيجه
كما قلت قبل قليل الشخصياته سلوكه سياسيات
ومواقفه يعتبر احد الاشخاص الذين اثروا
بشكل يعني كبير جدا في حزب الجمهوري الحزب
الالي كان يقوم منقسم على ذاته حتى وان
كانت القسام غير ظاهر علنيا هناك محاولات
وكان بشكل عام هناك
تململ او رفض في بعض الاوساط الجمهوريه من
وجود دونالد ترامب هناك رفض لسلوك ولكن
هناك محاوله لدعمه على الاقل حتى لا يختار
اصواتهم في الانتخابات المقبله وبالتالي
بنتكلم على وضع سياسي ملتهب ومستقطب لحد
بعيد لكن ايضا موضوع موضوع جنائي بالاساس
بنتكلم على ترامب الان ليس رئيسا ترامب
شخص عادي مواطن امريكي عادي يخضع للقانون
ليس هناك احد فوق القانون في امريكا
وبالتالي هو يتعرض الان لمحاكمه جنائيه مت
اما بي طبعا حتى اللحظه لا نعرف خديجه
لاحد اتهامات لانها يعني سريه حتى هذه
اللحظه ربما عرفها بعد قليل لكن بشكل عام
بنتكلم على ما يشاع او ما يثار حول
اتهامات متعلقه بالتهرب الضريبي متعلقه
بشراء الصمت من احد الاشخاص متعلقه باموال
غير قانونيه تنخابيه في 2016 فبنتكلم على
يعني جرائم هي جرائم جنائيه او حتى على
الاقل جنح او مخالفات ماليه واداريه وبشكل
عام نتكلم على بعد قضائي بعد قوانين طبعا
الصعب نفس القضيه عن قانوني في الحاله
الامريكيه حاليا على الاقل طيب ينضم الينا
الان ادلف فرانكو المحلله للاستراتيجي في
الحزب الجمهوري هنا ان نعرف سيد
موقف الجمهوريين وكيف يتابعون هذه
المحاكمه للرئيس الامريكيه السابق دونالد
ترامب
في الحقيقه ان الحزب الجمهوري يتابعوا عن
كثب ما يحصل بالنسبه الى
87% من الجمهوريين هذا استمرار لعمليه
الملاحقه والاضطهاد السياسي لدونالد ترامب
وذلك بدا قبل الرئاسته يمكننا ان نتذكر ان
عددا كبيرا من
الديمقراطيين في الكونجرس ارادوا ان
يعزلوا الرئيس ترامب باضافه الى ذلك
شاهدنا الدعوه المتلاحقه لمنع الرئيس
ترامب من الاستمرار في سته الرئاسيه
وبالتالي هذا استمرار في نفس السياق
وللسوء الحظ قد وضع البلاد في وضع غير
مسبوق على المستوى القضائي وان المدعي
مدعي عامه منطقه نيويورك السيد براك قرر
ان هناك ادله تسمح له بالمحاكمه نحن لا
نعرف ما هي لائحه الاتهام اذا ما كان
الامر يرتبط بالتهمه بشان ستورمي دانيز
هذا ليس بالامر الجديد لقد عبر
المواطنون الامريكيون عن رايهم بشان هذه
النقطه في الصادق وبالتالي لا نعرف الان
سوف يحصل
نقرا حال يعني
هل يعني استمعت الان الى السيد ادول
فرانكو ان الرجل يعني يتعرض لملاحقه يتعرض
لعمليه اضطهاد وهذا ليس بالجديد وسبق ان
تعرض لذلك عندما كان رئيسا للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بمحاولات عزله وبالتالي
هذه الحلقه هي جزء من المسلسل السابق الذي
شهده الرئيس دونالد ترامب كيف ترى هذا
الكلام كيف ترد عليه
المشكله في السماعكم هناك اصوات كثيره
متداخله اذا كان سؤالكم ما هو ردي عن ما
سمعته حول مساله تسييس هذه القضيه برمتها
وهذه تهمه الجمهوريون وخاصه قاعده دونالد
ترامب وانصاره
سيكررونه بغض النظر عما يقول حتى اذا كان
الطبيعه
التهم لم تكن جنائيه فقاعدتها انصاره
سيسرون على انها قضيه سياسيه هو طبعا بحكم
شخصيته وانا ما سمعته هو لن يتحدث امام
القاضي الا عندما يرد على التهم ويدفع
بانهم
بها او لا لكن هذا من ناحيه القانوني اما
من ناحيه السياسيه فهو يطلق احكامه ضد
القضاه والقاضي نفسه والمدعي العام كيف هو
مضطهد وهذا
الهراء السياسي لكن شخصيتها الاخرى تدرك
ان هذه قضيه خطيره وجاده وهو يدرك ايضا ان
هناك قضايا اكثر خطوره تنتظره ربما في
قضيه
جورجيا والاصوات الانتخابيه واخفاء
الوثائق في مارلاجو اما قضيه ستورميدان
ربما قضيه تساعده على صرف الانظار عن
القضاء الاخطر وان يخاطب قاعدته وجمهوره
بانه مضطهد سياسيا وليستخدم الحشد الذي
تايد الذي يحفظه في قضيه مارلوجو وقضيه
جورج طب في هذه النقطتين بالذات
سيد ذكرى
جورجيا والوثائق المخفيه وغير ذلك لو
حاولنا ان نخمن او نتكهن
ما الذي يمكن ان تكون عقوبه تهم مثل هذه
الرغم ان التهم ليست يعني ما زالت غير
معروفه
رسميا طبعا
انا لا انا لست طبعا
قانونا لكن اذا ما استندنا الى قضايا
سابقه ربما لم تكن ضد رؤساء رؤساء لكن ضد
اشخاص عملوا في مجال الامن القومي عندما
اخفى وثائق سريه تعرضوا لعقوبه السجن
ومقابل
اقل بكثير مما نسمعه من اتهامات قد توجه
ضد دونالد ترامب في قضيه مارلاجو حتى
الجمهوريين يقرون بانه لا احد فوق القانون
وانا اتوقع ان هناك قضايا اخطر خطوره اكثر
خطوره سيواجهها في المستقبل دكتور خليل
عناني يعني بتهم اقل يقول نكرهها من اقل
اناس دخلوا السجن بتهم اقل بكثير من التهم
التي يواجهها دونالد تر امب وهو الان
مواطن عادي يحاكم هل هذه القضيه ستضر به
كثيرا ام بالعكس ربما تخدمه من يدري ربما
يعني استخدمه في الانتخابات في اذا ترشح
للانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله
الامر يتوقف على نتيجه ما يحدث اليوم هل
نحن ازاء ادانه حقيقيه له ام ان قد يكون
هناك احد ما سمعته خلال الايام الماضيه من
خبراء قانون في امريكا هناك ثلاث
سيناريوهات لهذه المحاكمه الاول المتعلق
بصرف وعدم ادانته واعتبار ما حدث مجرد
مخالفه اداريه وبالتالي عدم وضع ايداعه في
السجن الامر الثاني متعلق باتهامه بالقيام
بجنحه وقد يكون عقوباتها دفع غرامه ماليه
ثم الانصراف قد يكون السيناريو الثالث
متعلق باعتبار ان هذه او جنيه او جريمه
وبالتالي حكم عليه اما بعام عامين حتى
اربعه اعوام كحد اقصى بشكل عام من الناحيه
السياسيه بلا شك ومن منذ اليوم الاول
عندما تم الاعلان هذه المساله الخميس
الماضي قام باستثمار هذا الموضوع سياسيا
وراينا المساله عندما ولن فتح باب
التبرعات حماته الانتخابيه جمع على الاقل
في اول ليله اربعه مليون دولار على سبعه
على ثمانيه مليون دولار جمعها نجد حماته
الانتخابيه الامر الثاني هو سوف يقوم
بتوظيف هذه اقل من اجل دعم حدوده داخل حزب
الجمهوري بالاساس خاصه هناك نوع من
المنافسه مع حاكم ولايه فلوريدا ديسانتوس
الذي يعتبر الى حد بعيد وجه مقبول لدى
العقل الاوساط المعتاده في حزب الجمهوري
وهناك ميل لانتخابه رشح نفسه انتخابات
القادمه الامر الثاني متعلق لو تم دائره
طبعا دستوريه من حقه ان يترشح في
الانتخابات لكن ايضا سيكون هناك عبء نفسي
واخلاق ان يقوم بالترشيح شخصيه لديها سجل
جنائي هذا لم يحدث على على الاطلاق من قبل
في تاريخ امريكا وبالتالي من احد استغل
السياسي هو موجود منذ اليوم الاول لهذه
المساله وقد يكون هذه المحاكمه هديه اعتبر
من فضه لترامب كي يقوم الانتخاريه منها
ونعلم جميعا انه بعدما يتم اطلاق سراحه
اليوم وهو في اغلب الاحوال سيطلق سراحه
باي شكل من الاشكال سوف يعقد المؤتمر صحفي
في فلوريدا عند يعني اخر اليوم في امريكا
سوف يعل من خلاله ترشيحه الانتخابات بشكل
حقيقي من خلال تصوير الموضوع باعتباره
سياسي كما قيل قبل ق انه شهيد للنظام
العالقه في امريكا يعتبر هناك استهداف
شخصي له من قبل الديمقرا وبالتالي هو يقوم
بشحد القاعده الجمهوريه خلفه في
الانتخابات المقبله بشكل عام هناك استخدام
سياسي للموضوع ترامب يعني ذكي جدا في هذه
المساله لديه سجل طويل في استغلال كل ما
يتعلق بشخصيته بالاجل التحويله من بعد شخص
لبعد سياسي والامر الملفت هنا انه صحيح في
امريكا قد يكون امر غير مسبوق لكن بشكل
عام في العالم هناك حالات اخرى لرؤساء
سابقين تمح محاكمتهم يعني مثلا كان هناك
اتهام في فرنسا بالفساد وحكم عليه ابتهال
مثلا
الاسباق وتم ايضا حكم عليه نعم لكن
سالكوزي لم تم لكن نعم تم اتهامه وتم
محاكمته طيب
او لا يسجل دعني اعود الى فرانكو مستشار
في الحزب الجمهوري
يعني مدينه تخيل قليلا المشهد خصوصا عندما
نتابع في الاخبار العاجله التي نقراها على
الشاشه ترامب يقول سيعتقلونني ولا اصدق ان
ذلك يحدث في امريكا في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هل يمكن ان نتخيل هذا المشهد
الرئيس الامريكي السابق ترامب يلبس لباس
السجناء موجود في سجن يعني بعد المحاكمه
هل هذا مطروح فعلا تراه احتمالا مطروحا
بقوه الان في هذه المحاكمه
اي شيء ممكن ولكن اجد انه من المثير
للاهتمام اننا نتحدث عن الحكم قبل توجيه
الاتهامات بشكل رسمي وقبل المحاكمه نحن
لسنا في الاتحاد السوفيتي نحن في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هذه المشكله بالملاحقه
والاتهاض السياسي الذي نشهده الان اولا
السيد سالكوزي ليس في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هذا لم يحصل من قبل في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه دونا ترامب لم يتعرض
لاي تهمان مباشره لقد قدم ايضا هناك امثله
متعدده في العام 2016 مدير الاف بي اي
تحدث عن ان هلري كلينتن قدر ارتكبت جرائم
ولكن ما من مدعي عام قام بتوجيه تهم الى
السيده كلينتون كما يفعلون الان مع السيد
ترامب
الى المشاهدين الكرام يجب ان يفهموا ان
المدعي العام هو شخصيه سياسيه هو ديمقراطي
هو كان ضد دونالد ترامب اذا ما لم يكن هذا
بالتسيس لا اعرف ما هو التسيس اما بالنسبه
الى الضيف الاخر الذي تحدث عن دعم قاعده
ترامب ولكن نحن نتحدث عن دعم عارم في
اوساط الحزب الجمهوري
87% بما في ذلك من قبل الجهات التي سوف
تعلن المرشحين المقبلين
للرئاسه من جانب الفزب الجمهوريه وبالتالي
هناك دعم عارم من ضمن الحزب الجمهوري
والنقطه الاخيره بالنسبه الى السيناريو
النظريه طبعا بعد
المحاكمه في نيويورك ما من احد دخل الى
السجن لانه خرق القوانين الانتخابيه
الفيدراليه والتي يبدو ان اساس لائحه
الاتهام طبعا لائحه الاتهام يمكن ان تجزا
الى اقسام متعدده وبالتالي يمكن ان نجمع
بعض التهم لكي يكون لديها شكل اسوا ولكن
ما من وقع قانونيا وبالتالي ما من احد دخل
السجن في هذا السيناريو لذلك اشك بهذه
الامكانيه اذا ما حصل ذلك ولكن اشك
بامكانيات حصول ذلك قد يكون ذلك نهايه
الديمقراطيه الامريكيه ودونالد ترامب اول
سجين سياسي في الولايات المتحده طب
العواجل تتوالى طبعا بخصوص هذه المحاكمه
احتجاز ترامب بالمحكمه لاخذ بصمته ايضا
البيت الابيض يقول
مستعدون لاي تهديد نكره حال هذا هذا
الموقف من البيت الابيض الذي طبعا رفض
التعليق على القضيه ولكن قال انهم مستعدون
لاي تهديد نقف عند كلمه اي تهديد ما
التهديد المحتمل عن اي تهديد يتحدث البيت
الابيض
برايك
انا لا فكره لدي على الاطلاق عن اي تهديد
هل قلتم ان البيت الابيض يتحدث عن تهديد
هذه اخبار مفاجئه تماما
رغم انا عندي الثقه الكامله بكم لكن لا
اعتقد ان هذا سيحصل اليوم او ما يشبه ما
حصل في السادس من يناير عندما حرض عليه
دون ترامب هو على مدى اليومين الماضيين
على الاقل
استمع الى نصائح فريق القانوني المشكل
حديثا والذين نصحوه بان يلتزم الصمت لكي
لا توجه اليه التهم اخرى بتحريض ما يسمونه
بالجرذان في الشوارع الامريكيه اي انصارهم
من الغوغائيين وطبعا
الان يجمع ملايين الدولارات من خلال
تصريحاته
بسبب هذه التهم هذه الاموال يستخدمها
دونالد ترامب لكن هي تجمع من امريكيين هم
ينتمون الى قاعدته الانتخاب اسعارهم
يؤمنون بكل كلمه ينطق بها اذا هو على
المدى القريب وانا اؤكد على المدى القريب
سيستفيد من لائحه التهم وهو الان
يتقلب بنعم الله من تاييد كبير له في
اوساط الحزب الجمهوري لكن على المدى
البعيد سنرى سنرى
كما تدين تدان كما يقولون ولا شيء يتغير
مثل ما تتغير الامور في السياسه دكتور
خليل
نرى وان غدا لنظره قريب سنرى ما الذي
سيحدث ما الذي سيحدث قبل قليل
ادولفو فرانكو قال هذه القضيه تنظر بنهايه
الديمقراطيه الامريكيه هل تراها بالفعل
تنظر بنهايه الديمقراطيه الامريكيه
لا على الاطلاق نحن ذاء مرحله جديده من
محاوله تجزير حكم المؤسسات في امريكا لابد
ان نفرق بين ما هو قانوني وقضائي وما هو
السياسي رغم ان هناك بالفعل يعني شبهه
سياسيه طبعا كل شيء في امريكا متعلق
بالسياسه خاصه فيما يتعلق بالصراع
لكن بشكل عام بنتكلم على مؤسسات قضائيه
قانونيه تحترم الى حد بعيد ما يحدث حتى
هذه اللحظه هو عباره عن عمليه قضائيه
قانونيه القضاء في امريكا مستقل لحد بعيد
ونجح احترام وثقه من كثير من الامريكيين
فيما تعلق بالقضاء الامريكي وبالتالي اي
نتيجه سوف تظهر عنها محاكمه اليوم سوف يتم
احترامها بشكل او باخر كما قلت قبل قليل
نتكلم على
مواطن امريكا عادي حدث انه كان رئيسا
سابقا طبعا بالفعل هناك تاثير كبير
للترامب باعتبار رمز سياسي باعتباري شخصيه
جدليه بشكل عام وفي النهايه مواطن امريكي
لا يتمتع باي حصانه قضائيه وقانونيه في
المرحله الحاليه وليس في السلطه وبالتالي
من حق امريكا ليقوم بملاحقته
واتهامها حتى حبسه اذا كان هناك بالفعل
اثبات لهذه التهم فانا مختلف تمام حد بعيد
نحن عندما يقول الضيف الامريكيه بالعكس
نحن ازاء محاوله جديه حكم القانون ان ليس
هناك احد فوق القانون ان كل من يقوم
باختراق القانون او بانتهاك سواء كان
رئيسا سابقا او رئيسا حاليا او مسؤولا
امريكيا سوف يخضع للمحاكمه يخضع للتحقيق
وبالتالي هذا يعتبر اضافه وليس خصم
الامريكيه كما يدعي البعض
دائما في سياق نفس هذه الفكره وانت تحدثت
عن انه هذه القضيه تنظر بنهايه
الديمقراطيه الامريكيه لماذا لا نقول تنظر
بنهايه رجل سياسي تمبر بنهايه ترامب كرجل
سياسي وليس بنهايه ديمقراطيه الامريكيه هل
هي نهايه
نتحدث عن امر يتخطى الرئيس ترامبو بكثير
نحن نتحدث عن نظاما برمته انا اتفق مع
فكره ان النظام القضائي مستقل ولكن يمكن
ان نشهد انتهاكات على مستوى الادعاء العام
نحن نتحدث عن مدعيا عام هو شخص منتخب
سياسيا في نيويورك وبالتالي لائحه الاتهام
التي تقدمت بها هيئه المحلفين في نيويورك
والتي هي الليبراليه ديمقراطيه معارضه
لترامب
وثمانيه وتسعون بالمئه من لوائح حال
الاتهام تتقدم بها الهيئه ويسمح بها
القاضي اما بالنسبه الى ما تفضل به الضيف
الاخر بانه ما من احد فوق القانون في هذه
الحاله الرئيس ترامب يخضع للقانون هذه
مساله كان يفترض ان تكون فيدراليه ولكنها
الان تحاكم على مستوى الولايه لم يؤخذ بها
منذ سنوات على المستوى الفيدرالي وها هي
تستخدم الان على المستوى السياسي اذا ما
كنا نتحدث عن التصرف بالتساوي يمكننا ان
نعود الى هيرلي كلينتون
والرسائل الالكترونيه انا انتظر التحقيق
بذلك وايضا الرئيس الاسبق كلينتن الذي كذب
تحت القسم وبالتالي هناك امثله متعدده نحن
نتحدث عن معيار جديد من الاضطهاد السياسي
الان انا الاوان بالنسبه الى الديمقراطيين
ان يتصرفوا بهذا الشكل هذا معيار جديد
لربما يطبق على كل الخصوم السياسيين الامر
يتخطى السيد ترامب هذا هجوم على
الديمقراطيه
الرئيس كلنتا مره بتحقيقات مفصله للغايه
قادها كنستار على ما اتذكر وهو
جمهوري كانت هناك تهم في ذلك الوقت بان
اعداء كلينتن السياسيون كانوا يترصدون
الله اذا هذه دائما تسمع من الطرف الاخر
هذا جزء من كيفيه عمل نظامنا الديمقراطي
ان تقول سواء كان قولك حق او باطل بان ما
يوجه لك من تهم ذا الطبيعه السياسيه او لا
نظامنا ديمقراطيه سينجو
افضل نظام
شكرا جزيلا لك ونعتذر للانتهاء وقت
البرنامج شكرا جزيلا لك نكره حال من
فيرجينيا عضو الكونجرس السابق عن الحزب
الديمقراطي وشكرا ايضا
فرانكو المحلل الاستراتيجي في الحزب
الجمهوري والدكتور خليل العناني شكرا لكم
جميعا لكم ان اطيب المنى والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]